THE UNITED STATES WAS ACTUALLY A
FULL PARTNER IN THIS, AND THEN
AFTER THE WAR WHEN THE UNITED
STATES, EXCUSE ME, WHEN EUROPE
WAS IN SHAMBLES, WHEN EUROPE WAS
BURNING AND WHEN PEOPLE WERE
STARVING AND FAMILIES WERE
SEPARATED IBM CAN AND WHAT THEY
CLAIM FOR LOST SHIPPING BOXES
AND FOR SCOTCH TAPE AND THEY
RECOVERED ALL OF THE PROFITS
THAT WERE LOCKED AWAY FOR IBM
THROUGH PRE-AGREEMENT IN SWISS
BANKS.
..
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF MAYBE THE
UBS.
NONE OF THE BANKS WAS INVOLVED
IN THE PUNCH CARD MACHINES.
NONE OF THE BANKS WERE INVOLVED
IN SLAVE LABOR.
AND IT WAS JUST FINANCING.
PARDON ME?
HOW DID THEY FINANCE IT?
THEY FINANCED IT THROUGH SPIDER
WEBS OF CONNECTIONS.
FOR INSTANCE WHEN GENERAL MOTORS
WANTED TO GET FOREIGN EXCHANGE
TO PAY FOR ITS PARTS FROM NAZI
GERMANY, NAZI GERMANY SAYS WE
DON'T HAVE THE FOREIGN CURRENCY.
WE WILL GIVE YOU PENCILS, WE
WILL GIVE YOU CHRISTMAS LIGHTS
AND YOU CAN SELL THOSE IN LATIN
AMERICA.
WHEN YOU GET THOSE MONIES YOU
CAN TRADE THEM OFF $4, WHICH GO
THROUGH VARIOUS KINDS OF
TRANSFER AGREEMENTS AND
REMEMBER, I WROTE THE BOOK THE
TRANSFER AGREEMENTS AND KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
YOUR THIRD QUESTION WAS WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE UNITED
STATES?
LEO WILL HAVE TO HAVE ME BACK
ANOTHER TIME.
WHO ELSE HAS ANOTHER QUESTION?
THIS GENTLEMAN HERE.
>> IBM DURING THE WARHEAD
ENABLING THE GERMANS TO COMMIT
THEIR CRIMES?
>> WERE THE TECHNICIANS ENABLING
THE GERMANS TO COMMIT THEIR
CRIMES?
NOT ONLY WERE THEY ENABLING IT,
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN WITH RIVALS WITHOUT
BOLLES.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH THE PUNCH
CARDS, WITH A PUNCH CARD
MACHINES WITHOUT PUNCH CARDS?
THEY WERE THE EXCLUSIVE FRONTIER
OF THE PUNCH CARDS.
THE MACHINES HAD TO BE RESET FOR
GOOD THEY HAD TO BE WIRED.
THEY HAVE TO TRAIN PEOPLE HOW TO
USE THEM.
REMEMBER THESE ARE COMPLICATED
MACHINES.
NOT EVERYBODY COULD USE THESE
THE TECHNICIANS THEM EXACTLY
WHAT WAS GOING ON, BECAUSE WHEN
YOU ARE IN AUSCHWITZ AND YOU
HAVE TO DIFFERENTIATE HOW TO
PUNCH A CARD, WHETHER A MAN HAS
BEEN HUNG, DROPPED DEAD,
COMMITTED SUICIDE, OR BEEN SENT
TO A GAS CHAMBER, THAT TAKES A
LOT OF INVOLVEMENT.
YOU KNOW, THERE WERE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF CONCENTRATION
CAMPS ACROSS EUROPE, IN WHICH
PEOPLE OF ALL NATIONALITIES AND
ALL RELIGIONS AND ALL SOCIAL
SEGMENTS WIND AND AND OUT ON A
DAILY BASIS, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
BUT THE ONE DAY POPULATION
CAPACITY OF ALL CONCENTRATION
CAMPS PUT TOGETHER WAS BETWEEN
325,375,000.
THAT IS TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT.
THAT WAS THE MAGIC OF IBM AND
ITS TECHNICIANS.
NEXT.
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR YOU.
>> COULD YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
WHERE GERMANY GOT THE OIL AND
GASOLINE TO RUN THESE TRACKS?
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
>> THAT IS MY BOOK, BANKING ON
BAGHDAD.
I AM SORRY, THAT IS MY BOOK,
INTERNAL COMBUSTION.
MY BOOK, INTERNAL COMBUSTION,
THEY GOT SOME FROM ROMANIA BUT
THEY WORKED WITH JERUSALEM.
NO, THEY GOT IT FROM BRITISH
PETROLEUM.
ANGLO PETROLEUM OIL COMPANY, AND
I HAVE CHECKED THEIR ARCHIVES,
WHICH CHANGED THEIR NAME TO
ANGLO EYE RINI IN AND ANGLO IN
TURKISH PETROLEUM OVER VARIOUS
ITERATIONS,LTIMATELY BECAME
BRITISH PETROLEUM AND THEY WERE
SELLING OIL TO THE NAZIS, BUT
WAS MOST IMPORTANT IS THAT THE
ARABS WERE ENGINEERING OIL TO
THE NAZIS THROUGH JERUSALEM AND
ENCOURAGING THE NAZIS TO SEND
JEWS TO DEATH CAMPS AND THIS IS
THE JERUSALEM, AND I BELIEVE
THIS IS ANOTHER AREA IN WHICH
YOU ARE FINDING THE HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM TO INCLUDE THIS HISTORY.
WHO ELSE HAS A QUESTION?
IN THE BACK.
PARDON ME?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THE MUSLIMS--
>> HIS NAME WAS HUSSEIN AND HE
WAS A MUSLIM.
YES.
>> I AM MIRIAM STEARN.
I AM REALLY NOT EMBARRASSED TO
SAY I NEVER HEARD OF YOU, I
NEVER READ A BOOK AND I AM
SHOCKED BY THE WHOLE THING.
I AM WONDERING, HOW DO YOU GET
YOUR MESSAGE OUT SO MORE PEOPLE
KNOW BESIDES TALKING TO SMALL
GROUPS OF THE CONVERTED.
FOR INSTANCE, IS THERE A
DOCUMENTARY?
ARE YOU PLANNING A DOCUMENTARY?
>> OKAY, THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE REACH THE MASS MEDIA?
NOT JUST SMALL GROUPS LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING YOUR
QUESTION.
THE REALITY IS, I DO SCORES OF
THE EVENTS EVERY YEAR AND I GIVE
THE MESSAGE TO SMALL GROUPS OF
100 AS MANY AS 1500 AT A TIME.
I SPEAK TO SURVIVORS.
I SPEAK TO YOUNG PEOPLE.
I SPEAK TO CHRISTIAN GROUPS, TO
JEWISH GROUPS, I SPEAK TO ALL
SORTS OF GROUPS.
THERE IS A DOCUMENTARY OUT RIGHT
NOW.
YOU CAN FIND IT AT "WAR AGAINST
THE WEAK" MOVIE.COM.
IT IS IN THE FESTIVALS.
IT TELLS THE EUGENIC STORY I
TOLD ABOUT.
IT WON THE BEST MOVIE OF THE
YEAR AWARD FROM THE BEVERLY
HILLS FILM FESTIVAL.
I HAVE OTHER MOVIES IN
PRODUCTION, WHICH I CANNOT
DISCUSS AT THIS TIME.
I WRITE FOR THE CUTTING EDGE
NEWS, WHICH YOU CAN FIND AT THE
CUTTING EDGE NEUSTADT, AND I
ALSO HAVE A PERSONAL WEB SITE
THAT HE MIGHT TAKE NOTICE OF, IT
IS EDWIN BLACK.COM.
NOT ONLY DO I SPEAK TO PEOPLE
WHO KNOW THIS INFORMATION, BUT
THE REASON I SPEAK IS BECAUSE
THERE ARE STILL MANY PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW THIS INFORMATION AND
NO MATTER WHAT I HAVE TOLD YOU,
MAAM MATTER WHAT I HAVE
PUBLISHED, I HAVE ONLY SCRATCHED
THE SURFACE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> HAVE THE CUTTING EDGE NEWS
THAT COME.
WE REACH ABOUT 1 MILLION PEOPLE
A MONTH.
YES MAAM.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW, I MEAN
I UNDERSTAND NOW YOU HAVE MANY
SPONSORS BUT AT THE BEGINNING,
WHO SPONSORED YOU?
YOU HAVE TO TRAVEL A LOT.
>> THE QUESTION WAS-- HOW MUCH
TIME DO WE HAVE LEO?
I NEED SOME WATER.
THE SPONSORS ME?
WHERE DO I GET THE MONEY TO
TRAVEL ETC., ETC..
I HAVE NO FOUNDATION GRANTS.
THE PERPETRATORS' DID NOT
SPONSOR ME.
I AM NOT AN HISTORIAN FOR SALE.
I SPEAK ALL OVER THE COUNTRY AND
I'M SPONSORED BY UNIVERSITY
GROUPS OR CHURCHES, SYNAGOGUES,
FEDERATIONS, BUT I CAME UP
YESTERDAY ON AMTRAK, USING MY
POINTS AND I STAYED IN A VERY
INEXPENSIVE HOTEL, WHICH IS MY
ARRANGEMENT WITH LEO, BECAUSE
I'M SO INTERESTED TO SPEAK TO
YOU FOLKS.
I ASSURE YOU, IF ONE OF THE
MAJOR CORPORATE CRIMINALS
DECIDED TO INVESTIGATE ITSELF,
THEY WOULD GET THE BIG HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM HISTORIANS.
THAT WOULD PAY THEM A COUPLE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AN HOUR AND I
WOULD BE ON THE OUTSIDE.
I AM NOT FOR SALE.
MY INFORMATION IS NOT FOR SALE,
AND IT IS OBJECTIVE AND WHEN I
THOUGHT HENRY FORD DID A LOT TO
GET THIS COUNTRY OFF OF OIL AND
INTO A CAR, I WROTE THE BOOK
INTERNAL COMBUSTION, WHEN I KNEW
HENRY FORD WAS THE BIGGEST
HOLOCAUST AND IDEOLOGICAL
SPONSOR OF ADOLF HITLER IN THE
EARLY 20'S.
I WROTE THE TRANSFER AGREEMENT
AND NOT THE NEXUS.
SO, IT IS A CONSTANT BATTLE TO
TELL THE TRUTH, BUT IT IS NEVER
A CONSTANT BATTLE TO HAVE THE
TRUTH BE REMEMBERED.
WHO ELSE HAS A QUESTION?
WE ARE GETTING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BUT YOU ARE CLOSE
HERE.
>> DOES ANYBODY ELSE DO THAT
KIND OF RESEARCH?
SIMILAR TO YOURS?
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MY NAME IS RITA.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.
ONE IS, DID THE INVOLVEMENT OF
THE AMERICAN CORPORATIONS IN
NAZI GERMANY CHANGE ONCE AMERICA
GOT INTO THE WAR OR NOT, BECAUSE
WHEN THE RABBI WHO WANTED TO
TRADE JEWISH LIVES FOR TRUCKS,
THE AMERICAN AND OTHER FREE
NATIONS OF THE WORLD DID NOT
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE MONEY
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY CAN'T
GIVE MONEY TO AN ENEMY
TERRITORY.
THAT WAS ONE QUESTION.
>> GIVE ME THAT QUESTION.
>> IN OTHER WORDS, IBM AND ALL
THESE DIFFERENT CORPORATIONS FOR
ALL HEADQUARTERED IN NAZI
GERMANY AND POLAND AND THE
OCCUPIED TERRITORY, BUT AMERICA
WAS NOT IN THE WAR YET.
ONCE AMERICA ENTERED THE WAR,
DID THAT CHANGE, DID THEY GET
OUT?
WHAT DID THEY DO?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> WHATEVER IT WAS, THAT GROUP,
THE WORKING GROUP FROM
CZECHLESLOVAKIA?
>> DO YOU HAVE A SECOND
QUESTION?
>> I HAVE BEEN RAISED MY WHOLE
LIFE BY GERMAN THIS INTERNET.
MAYBE WE SHOULD NOT BE BUYING
AMERICAN.
>> OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
LET ME ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS.
HITLER CAME TO POWER ON
JANUARY 30TH OF 1933 AND THE
ANTI-JEWISH LAW WENT INTO EFFECT
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
THE NUREMBURG ALAA, 1937,
KRISTALNACHT 1938.
THE WORLD WAR II STARTED AT
6:00 A.M., OR SOME POLISH PEOPLE
LIKE TO SAY 3:00 IN THE MORNING,
SEPTEMBER 1, 1939.
WE WERE NOT BROUGHT INTO THE
EUROPEAN WAR UNTIL PEARL HARBOR
WAS BOMBED.
DURING THE INITIAL 30'S, THERE
WAS NO LAW AGAINST WORKING WITH
NAZI GERMANY.
THERE WAS A BOYCOTT.
YET, THE BOYCOTT WAS NOT ONLY
DID JEWISH.
THERE WAS THE UNIONS, THERE WAS
THE CHRISTIANS, THERE WERE THE
JEHOVAH'S WITNESSES.
THERE WERE LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE BEING PERSECUTED BY THE
THIRD REICH.
IN ORDER TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES
FROM NAZI GERMANY, THEY STARTED
TO RUN THINGS THROUGH GENEVA AND
TO PARIS AND FOR SWEDEN AND
OTHER AREAS.
IT BECAME INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
TO DO BUSINESS WITH GERMANY
AFTER 1937 BUT IT WAS DONE.
IN FACT IT BECAME THE QUESTION
OF THE HOUSE UN-AMERICAN
ACTIVITIES COMMITTEE, SOMETIMES
CALLED YOU WHICH BEGAN TO
INVESTIGATE COLLABORATORS WITH
THE THIRD REICH OF WHICH THERE
WAS NO GREATER COLLABORATORS
THAN THE ONE I HAVE MENTIONED.
THERE WAS NO GREATER
COLLABORATORS THAN THE ONES THAT
I HAVE MENTIONED.
DURING, EVEN AFTER WE DECLARED
WAR-- EXCUSE ME, EVEN AFTER THE
WAR WAS DECLARED ON US IN
DECEMBER OF 1941, THE AMERICANS
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS WITH
THESE NAZI COS THROUGH
INTERMEDIARIES, THE KIND OF IN
THE SAME WAY THE OIL COMPANIES
DO BUSINESS WITH PROHIBITIVE
COMPANIES NOW THROUGH
SUBSIDIARIES.
IN FACT, I HAVE A DOCUMENT THAT
THE PUBLIC DEBT IBM ON THE
HOLOCAUST IN WHICH A GUY AND
CZECHLESLOVAKIA SAYS, WHILE
MR. WATSON, WE HAVE RELABELED
ARE NOT THE MACHINES AS
CZECHLESLOVAKIA MACHINES AND
THEY WILL NEVER KNOW, SAID THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS, THEY
DID CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
NAZI REGIME THROUGH
INTERMEDIARIES.
IN THE CASE OF GENERAL MOTORS
THEY WORKED THROUGH SOME
SUBSIDIARIES IN DENMARK.
YOUR OTHER QUESTION WAS-- WHAT
WAS YOUR OTHER QUESTION AGAIN?
SHOULD WE BOYCOTT AMERICAN
COMPANIES?
ALRIGHT, LOOK.
LOOK.
I USE IBM PRODUCTS.
THEY ARE DEADLY ACCURATE.
WE CAN'T BOYCOTT COMPANIES NOW
FOR WHAT WAS GOING ON THEN,
BECAUSE WE CAN'T EVEN SEND AN
E-MAIL TO GET THE VOY CUT GOING
WITHOUT IBM INVOLVED.
BUT, I SHOULD SAY THAT MANY OF
THESE COMPANIES HAVE CONFESSED
THEIR GUILT WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF IBM OR APOLOGIZE.
THE ISSUE OF REPARATIONS IS
SOMEBODY ELSE'S, IS A DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION AND I WOULD SAY HERE
THAT, IN FACT, I AM GOING TO
STOP FOR A MINUTE.
YOU SAID, WHO ELSE IS DOING THIS
WORK?
I DON'T TAKE CORPORATE MONEY.
SO, THESE COMPANIES WERE NOT
THAT BIG, AND DID NOT HAVE THAT
MUCH MONEY TO BUY IT OFF ALL OF
THE INSTITUTIONS IN QUESTION,
AND CERTAIN UNNAMED JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS, THERE WOULD BE
MANY MORE LIKE ME, SO I AM THE
ONLY ONE AND I DON'T TAKE ANY OF
THEIR MONEY.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED NOT TO
BOYCOTT THEM.
WE NEED TO CONFRONT THEM, WITH
THE TRUTH.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IS THEY
NEED TO TAKE A PAGE FROM THEIR
NAZI CLIENTS COME CONFESS WHAT
THEY DID, APOLOGIZE AND MOVE ON.
WHO HAS A QUESTION?
YES MAAM.
HOW ARE YOU, DEAR?
>> MY NAME IS TESTER.
I WANTED TO FIND OUT, AFTER THE
WAR, MCCARTHYISM WAS RAMPANT.
THEY WERE AFRAID OF THE SOVIET
UNION INFILTRATING THE AMERICAN
SCENE AMONG THE JEWS.
AND OF COURSE, THEY PAID A HIGH
PRICE IN HOLLYWOOD, BUT NOBODY
EVER BROUGHT ON ANYTHING ABOUT
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE NAZI AND
HOW MANY NAZIS SYMPATHIZERS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THERE WAS NO CONNECTION, NEVER
BROUGHT OUT AT ALL ABOUT THE
NAZIS.
ONLY ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
>> WELL, THERE WAS A LOT-- THE
REFERENCE TO THE MCCARTHY ERA
DID TRY TO FIND IT-- FIND A
COMMUNIST UNDER EVERY RAT BUT IN
THE PRIOR PERIOD, THEY TRIED TO
FIND A NAZI SYMPATHIZER UNDER
EVERY ROCK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER.
HAVE I EVER BEEN THREATENED?
DO YOU THINK A GUY IN A GOLF
SHIRT WITH A LOGO COULD THREATEN
ME?
IBM, GM, IT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WHAT IBM HAS BEEN DOING FOR THE
PAST DECADE IS THEY HAVE BEEN
HIDING.
THEY HAVE FAILED TO ANSWER.
THEY HAVE NOT ANSWERED ANY OF
THESE JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS.
THE LEADING INDEPENDENT
HISTORIANS.
THEY HAVE BOUGHT THEMSELVES A
BUNCH OF MUSEUMS.
BUNCH OF PROGRAMS.
THEY HAVE BOUGHT THEMSELVES A
BUNCH OF HISTORIANS AND THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WEISEL
THEMSELVES OUT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHEN THE GYPSIES SUED THEM IN
GENEVA THEY FOUGHT FOR YEARS
WITH THIS UNDERFUNDED GROUP, AND
THEY BASICALLY DID NOT SAY WE
DID NOT DO IT.
THEY SAID STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
I AM ALWAYS HERE FOR IBM IF THEY
NEED TO FIND ME.
WHO ELSE IS A QUESTION?
YOU ASK A BUNCH.
LET'S GO WITH THIS GUY BACK
HERE.
>> I HAVE DIFFICULTY
UNDERSTANDING ONE STATEMENT
ABOUT IBM.
ASSUMING THAT IBM--
EXTERMINATION WOULD PROCEED
ANYWAY BECAUSE WHEN THE GERMANS
WOULD COME ANYPLACE IN POLAND,
THEY WOULD JUST SAY EVERY JEW
HAS TO COME TOGETHER.
SO, WE DON'T HAVE EXACT
STATISTICS OR NAMES OF
EVERYBODY.
EXTERMINATIONS--
>> THE QUESTION IS, WITH THE
EXTERMINATIONS HAVE PROCEEDED
WITHOUT THE IBM?
THAT DID NOT-- THE NAZIS WOULD
HAVE COME INTO TOWN AND SAID ALL
JEWS COME TO THE CENTER OF THE
SQUARE AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
DO YOU THINK ALL OF THESE JEWS
ARE GOING TO COME IN AND SAY
HELLO, I AM A JEW, PUT ME IN A
TRUCK, SEND ME TO AUSCHWITZ.
THIS WAS THE WHOLE POINT AND
FIRST OF ALL I SHOULD SAY ONCE
AGAIN THERE WOULD HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN A HOLOCAUST.
WITHOUT IBM, WITHOUT GM, WITHOUT
FORD, WITHOUT CARNEGIE, WITHOUT
ROCKEFELLER BUT THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF HITLER'S HOLOCAUST, THE
ASTRONOMICAL NUMBERS WERE A
FUNCTION OF THE CORPORATE
COMPLICITY.
IT IS ONE THING TO COME IN WITH
A BULLHORN ON A GM TRUCK AND SAY
ALL JEWS ASSEMBLE AT NOON.
IT IS ANOTHER THING TO COME IN
WITH AN ALPHABETIZED LIST OF
ADDRESSES, BANK ACCOUNTS,
EVERYTHING AND SAY, WE KNOW WHO
YOU ARE.
EVERYBODY ON THIS LIST SHOW UP
AND IF YOU ARE NOT HERE, WE WILL
PICK YOU UP AND IF SOMEONE IS
HIDING YOU, WE WILL KILL THEM.
ANDEL FORGET THE WORK OF IBM WAS
NOT LIMITED TO STATISTICS AND
COUNTING.
THEY RAN THE BANK FOR
CONFISCATION.
THEY RAN THE TRAINS FOR THE
DEPORTATION AND THEY EVEN
DEVELOPED A SYSTEM CALLED
EXTERMINATIONS BY LABOR, WHICH
ALLOWED THE NAZIS TO WORK A MAN
TO DEATH AT SOME METED OUT TASK
BEFORE THEY WOULD EXTINGUISH HIS
LIFE.
IT WILL SAYS THE QUESTION?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THE IBM?
I AM SURE THEY CATALOG THAT AS
WELL.
LET'S GET TO THIS GENTLEMAN
HERE.
>> MY NAME IS LOU AND THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION.
REALLY PHENOMENAL.
I JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT WE
ARE STILL BEING HEARD BY THE
PROTOCOLS OF THE ELDERS OF ZION.
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
ITEMS IN ARAB COUNTRIES AND THAT
GIVES THEM THE REASON TO DO WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
>> THE QUESTION WAS, WHAT ABOUT
THE ARAB COUNTRIES THAT STILL
WORK WITH THE PROTOCOLS?
BOUQUET,-- OKAY, THE HOLOCAUST N
THE WAR AGAINST THE JEWS WAS
STOPPED IN MID 1945 IN EUROPE
AND WAS CONTINUED IN THE MIDDLE
EAST BY THE ARAB COUNTRIES WITH
THE HELP, GUIDANCE AND
SUPERVISION OF ESCAPING NAZI
GENERALS, COLONELS AND
LIEUTENANT AND CORPORATIONS.
THE PROTOCOLS OF THE ELDERS OF
ZION IS A BIG-TICKET IN THE ARAB
WORLD AND OF COURSE WAS PART OF
A CONTINUING MOVEMENT THAT WAS
BEGUN AND LED BY THE MUFTI OF
JERUSALEM.
HE WAS RECOMMENDED TO BE SLATED
FOR WAR CRIMES BY THE U.N..
THAT NEVER OCCURRED.
THAT WAS IN MY BOOK, BANKING ON
BAGHDAD, WHICH THEY ARE NOT TOO
MANY COPIES LEFT, AND THE REASON
HE WAS EXEMPTED IS BECAUSE,
BECAUSE OF THE OIL PRESSURES AT
THAT TIME.
NOW THOSE WHO HAVE ASKED, WHY
THERE IS A PHRASE THE MY BOOK
"NAZI NEXUS" FOR NOT INCLUDING
ANY OF THIS INFORMATION SHOULD
KNOW THAT THERE IS AN UNWRITTEN
RULE AT THE HOLOCAUST MUSEUM
THAT NO AMERICAN CORPORATION CAN
BE IMPLICATED IN ITS PERMANENT
EXHIBIT, AND YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO FIND ANY DAM, YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO FIND ANY FORD.
THEY HAVE GOT A WONDERFUL
EUGENICS PROJECT ON DISPLAY.
THERE IS NO ROCKEFELLER, ETC. ET
CEDRA.
WHO ELSE HAS A QUESTION?
YES MAAM.
>> GOALIE, GOLI.
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO DENIED
THE HOLOCAUST?
FOR EXAMPLE, THE PRESIDENT FROM
THE PALESTINIAN, NOBODY SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
HE DENIES THE WHOLE THING.
>> YOU MEAN THE PRESIDENT FROM
IRAN?
THE BOSS?
OKAY.
LET ME JUST CUT TO THE CHASE.
LET ME JUST CANNOT DANCE AROUND
THIS.
THE IRANIANS ARE NOW TRYING TO
DO, OR THE PRESIDENT OF IRAN IS
NOW TRYING TO DO AND 12 MINUTES
WITH HITLER COULD NOT DO IN 12
YEARS.
HE WANTS TO DESTROY ISRAEL AND
THE JEWS, AND MAYBE A BUNCH OF
OTHER PEOPLE SECOND, THIRD AND
FOURTH.
WHO IS PAYING FOR IT?
YOU ARE.
YOU ARE ON THE MILEAGE PLAN WITH
THE IRANIAN NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
I AM PAYING FOR IT.
EVERYONE WHO DRIVES A CAR IS
PAYING FOR IT.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> WELL, IT IS NOT A MATTER BUT
I DID WRITE ANOTHER BOOK CALLED
THE PLAN.
THANK YOU.
THAT CAN BE READ AT PLAN FOR OIL
CRISIS THAT COME.
WHY HAVE TO TELL YOU THE REASON
JEWISH GROUPS ARE INTERESTED IN
THIS COPY IS BECAUSE THE
REASON-- THE REASON JEWISH
GROUPS ARE INTERESTED IN THIS
TOPIC OF OIL ADDICTION.
I HAVE ALWAYS DEVOTED MYSELF TO
GENOCIDE, INJUSTICE, AND
RECOLLECTING AND DOCUMENTING A
HORRIBLE PAST TWO ENSURE A
PRECIOUS FUTURE.
IN THE CASE OF OIL, I AM
DOCUMENTING A PRECIOUS PAST TO
AVOID A HORRIBLE FUTURE.
ALMOST EVERYTHING YOU HEAR ABOUT
OIL ADDICTION, ALTERNATIVE
FUELS, IS FROM THE MEDIA, FROM
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, FROM BIG
CORPORATIONS.
IT IS EITHER LIE, AN
EXAGGERATION OR A DISTRACTION.
MOST OF YOU ARE PRETTY
INTERESTED IN THE GM VOLT WHICH
IS GOING TO PREMIERE SOMETIME
NEXT YEAR BUT THE LETTER CAR WAS
INVENTED IN 1835 AND ALL THE
CARS IN NEW YORK CITY IN THE
EARLY 1900'S WERE ELECTRIC CARS.
THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL FROM
HONDA, WHICH IS SUPPRESSING THE
HYDROGEN CAR AND THE CNG CAR IS
THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL WAS
INVENTED IN 1938.
THE FIRST HYDROGEN BUS WAS IN
1934.
THE FIRST HYDROGEN TRACTOR WAS
IN 1956.
THE FIRST HYDROGEN THAN IN 1958.
THE GERMAN NAVY HAS FIVE
SAVARD-- SUBMARINES ON HYDROGEN.
THERE IS ELECTRIC.
THERE ARE MANY ALTERNATIVES.
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW, WE ARE ON
THE VERGE OF THE OUTBREAK OF
HOSTILITIES BETWEEN ISRAEL AND
IRAN, AND THIS COUNTRY HAS NO
PLAN FOR AN OIL INTERRUPTION.
BARACK OBAMA DOES NOT HAVE WON,
McCAIN DOES NOT HAVE ONE, THE
DEMOCRATS DID NOT HAVE ONE, THE
REPUBLICANS DO NOT HAVE ONE, THE
IRANIANS ARE CONSTANTLY
THREATENING TO SHUT DOWN THE
STRAIT OF OR MOVED-- WYMUTH AND
IF THEY DO 20 PERCENT OF THE
GLOBAL SUPPLY, 20 PERCENT OF THE
SEABORNE OIL AND SOME 18 TO
20 PERCENT OF THE AMERICAN
SUPPLY WILL INSTANTLY STOP AND
OUR STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE
WILL LAST AROUND TWO MONTHS AND
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A CONTINGENCY
PLAN FOR IT.
AND SO, I BELIEVE WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING IS PART AND PARCEL, WHICH
IS WHY NEW ISRAELI LEADERS LIKE
NETANYAHU AND EVEN McCAIN HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES SAY, WE
WILL NOT ALLOW A SECOND
HOLOCAUST.
YOU MUST UNDERSTAND THERE HAS
BEEN A CONTINUITY OF OIL AND
HOLOCAUST SINCE THE FIRST DAYS
OF ADOLF HITLER, INCLUDING WHEN
HE INVADED RUSSIA.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS THAT.
WHO ELSE HAS A QUESTION?
PARDON ME?
[INAUDIBLE]
WHY DID THEY SWITCHED BACK?
>> WHY DID THEY SWITCH BACK TO
GASOLINE?
I DOCUMENTED THIS EXTENSIVELY IN
THE BOOK CALLED INTERNAL
COMBUSTION.
I WILL GIVE IT TO YOU SHORT.
ALL THE CARS IN THE UNITED
STATES WERE COLLECTOR CARS, ALL
THE TRUCKS IN THE UNITED
STATES-- THE NEI DECK CONECTIV?
>> KNEE DECK CONECTIV?
OKAY, SO ALL THE TRACKS WERE
ELECTRIC TRUCKS THAT WERE NOT
DRAWN OF COURSE BY FORCE.
1897 TO ABOUT 1911, AND FORD HAD
A SECRET PLAN WITH THOMAS EDISON
TO MAKE AN ELECTRIC MODEL-T, AND
THIS WAS ALL SUBVERTED BY
CORPORATE SUBTILIZE AND THE
FORCES OF "INTERNAL COMBUSTION."
IT IS A LONG STORY.
IT IS ANOTHER 40 MINUTE STORY
BUT IT IS IN MY BOOK, "INTERNAL
COMBUSTION."
WHY AREN'T THEY GOING BACK NOW?
WHY DID THEY SWITCH?
BASE WISH BECAUSE, I HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU, THEY THOUGHT
THAT THE ELECTRIC CAR WAS SO
QUIET AND SAYS SIMPLE IT WAS FOR
GIRLS, AND THEY WANTED A BIG,
MANLY CAR WITH THE BIG CRANK AND
A LOT OF NOISE AND EVERYTHING
ELSE, AND THIS WAS A MARKETING
DECISION MADE BY THE PEOPLE WHO
CONTROLLED THE PENS BACK IN THE
PERIOD BETWEEN 1909 AND 1914.
IT IS VERY WELL DOCUMENTED IN MY
BOOKS, BUT THE OTHER PART OF IT
IS THAT GENERAL MOTORS HEADED UP
THE CONSPIRACY WITH MAC TRUCK,
FIRESTONE, STANDARD AND
PHILIPPSON WHICH THEY BOUGHT UP
ALL THE ELECTRIC TROLLEYS, SOME
40 OF THEM AROUND THE COUNTRY,
AND TORE UP THE RAILS AND BURNED
THE TROLLEYS AND REPLACE THEM
WITH MOTORBUS IS, FOR WHICH
GENERAL MOTORS WAS INDICTED,
TRIED, CONVICTED AND THAT IS THE
REAL REASON WHY THE LETTER CAR
WAS KILLED.
WHO ELSE HAS A QUESTION?
THE LAST WHAT?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> IT IS PLANNED FOR THE OIL
CRISIS.COM.
OKAY, OR YOU CAN GO TO EDWIN
BLACK.COM.
LET ME GO TO THIS LADY.
YES MAAM.
>> IT IS JUST A COMMENT.
MY HUSBAND IS A MECHANICAL
ENGINEER.
HE READ EVERY WORD OF YOUR BOOK,
"IBM AND THE HOLOCAUST," AND HE
THINKS THAT YOU SHOULD FOCUS A
LOT OF YOUR SPEECHES ON
UNIVERSITY ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENTS.
>> WELL, I SPEAK ON EUGENICS TO
MEDICAL GROUPS, TO MEDICAL
COLLEGES BECAUSE OF COURSE THIS
WAS A FAKE MEDICAL SCIENCE,
WHICH WAS AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF HARVARD, PRINCETON, YALE,
STANFORD.
I DO SPEAK TO ATTORNEY GROUPS
ABOUT INTERNATIONAL LAW, ABOUT
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
IDS THE TWO ENGINEERING GROUPS
ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST.
I SPEAK TO A LOT OF I.T. GROUPS
BECAUSE MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE I.T. WORLD UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW I.T. WORKS.
THE UNDERSTAND WHAT DATABASE
THING IS AND THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
EASY IT WOULD BE TO SIMPLY
IDENTIFY A PERSON'S NAME AND
CROSS TABULATE THAT NAME AGAINST
HIS OTHER CHARACTERISTICS.
I AM JUST GOING TO TAKE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I'M RUNNING
OUT OF-- HERE.
THAT MEANS STRENGTH FOR YOU
GUYS.
WHO ELSE IS THAT A QUESTION THAT
DID NOT ASK ONE BEFORE?
THE WELLS HAS GOT ONE?
I WILL TAKE THIS ONE FOR THE
LAST ONE.
WHAT IS YOUR LAST-- YOUR NAME?
>> HENRY.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW, DO YOU
KNOW ROOSEVELT DID HIS BEST TO
NOT HELP THE JEWISH PEOPLE SEND
BACK CHIPS TO GERMANY TO BE
KILLED AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT
ARE A BUNCH OF ANTI-SEMITES.
WERE THEY INFLUENCED BY ALL OF
THESE COMPANIES--
>> THE QUESTION WAS, WERE ALL
THESE COMPANIES, WERE ALL THESE
POLITICIANS, WHO WERE ENGAGED IN
CERTAIN TYPES OF PASSIVE AND
OTHER TYPES OF EXCLUSION AND
COLLABORATION INVOLVING THE
JEWISH PERIOD INFLUENCED BY THE
CORPORATE COLLABORATORS OF THE
THIRD REICH SUCH AS IBM, GM ETC?
THE ANSWER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IS YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER EDWIN
BLACK IS THE AUTHOR OF MANY
BOOKS INCLUDING "IBM AND THE
HOLOCAUST," "WAR AGAINST THE
WEAK" AND THE PLAN.
FOR MORE INFORMATION, VISIT
EDWIN